Here are the facts
In 2013 video games are a 65
billion dollar industry
They are totally awesome AND...
playing them is good for you
Researchers at the University of Rockchester found students
who didn't play video games and divided them into 2 groups
They asked one group to play the visually complex game
Unreal Tournament while the other played the relatively
simple, not that it makes it a bad game, Tetris
After a month of near daily gaming
the Unreal Tournament players improved their vision
by nearly 20%. The Tetris players showed
no improvement. The most difficult part of the study
was finding students who didn't play video games
in the first place
A lot of people, mostly moms, say that video games can rot your brain,
but a neuro-research lab at UC San Francisco actually found the opposite to be true
They designed a video game called Neuro Racer to train cognitive functions
Their study showed people from ages 60 to 85 who played Neuro Racer
improved their multi-tasking and by the end of the study, some even
had the multi-tasking ability of a 20 year old
The researchers cautioned that you may not be able to get these
benefits from just any video game, so to make sure you're
covering your bases, you're gonna wanna play every video game all of the time
A deacon University study of pre-schoolers found that those who played
interactive video games were better at activities like throwing,
catching and kicking. In other words there is a generation of all-stars
growing up right now that is going to be amazing at both
video games and sports
Something you will often hear gamers say is "video games
can improve your reflexes", but did you know that it's actually true?
A study from the University of British Columbia found men who spend
at least three hours a week playing action video games had better reaction
times as well as improved focus and stronger target detection
Basically the stuff you need to be an astronaut, a baseball player,
a juggler you know, anything cool
PLOS, which sounds much more impressive when you find out it stands for
the Public Library of Science, recently published a study that found surgery
students who spent a month playing games like Wii Tennis performed better
in hand-eye coordination tests. So the next time someone tells you that
you're playing too many video games, send them this video
Let them know you're training to be a surgeon